I'll see you in hell
baby would have gotten them all if they
W so fast they're not moving
Ana for their first family vacation the
forgers travel to the snow covered land
of
fries yummy careful wandering off you
don't want you getting lost it's a
special night so I think it's okay for
Ana to stay up past her bedtime that
trip you must retrieve the microfilm
without fate ended up holding the fate
of the
world this will lead to warar between
East and
West what a nosy little girl kill
[Music]
her don't tell me Anya's gotten herself
mixed up with the military fire war's
coming anyway no matter what we can't
give up now if that microfilm ends up in
the wrong hands it could alter the fate
of the world uhoh I in in trouble let's
do this as a family is that all you've
got eliminate them I'm going to save
them wait for me
Ana spy Family Code
white I'll get them back whatever it
takes